[Musique]
le détatouage la douleur un peu l'odeur
beaucoup l'argent suffisamment
non pour faire peau neuve et effacer une
erreur de jeunesse
jean-marc doit en passer par là mieux
vaut bien se tâter avant de se tatouer
un tatouage est garantie 6 mois après la
main
je ne pouvais pas travailler les manches
avec des manches courtes
je suis verte et donc vous étudiez la
clientèle de ma direction tout ça j'ai
toujours caché mon mon problème commun
une maladie comme ça me gênait beaucoup
les gens qui demandent le détatouage
sont des gens qui ont qui ont fait ça 13
14 ans qui regrette ou qui ont fait ça
parce qu'ils ont fait de la prison qui
se sont racheter une conduite et le
détatouage est une de ces étapes de ce
rachat
l'image du passé s'en va la cicatrice
diminuera mais restera du tatouage qui
est parti ça fait un poids énorme de moi
je peux déjà me sentir gagne d'avis
quand même beaucoup plus belles pima
pour ma femme aussi on sera pas
catalogué tout de suite dans la
hiérarchie des de louer des branches
[Musique]